well I'm joined by Vice Marshall
thanks very much for being with us now
this map as we've seen for the past few
days hasn't really changed very much
what does that tell us about where we
are at this point in the war we got very
used to having a look at this map in
various uh through various media outlets
and I think we're always looking for the
changes
um and the danger is when nothing
changes we think people are perhaps
having a day off clearly nothing's
further from the truth what I think
we're seeing now is that having stalled
in their offensive we're seeing a
massive resupply from Russia whether
it's fuel Logistics weapons ready for
the next push
and that'll be troops and material
coming in from Russia to resupply
bolster those areas that they wouldn't
take them yes I think in terms of we've
got to look at where the priorities are
most wars certainly apart from 1945 are
not not one by the last man standing
there are negotiated position I think
we've seen the glimmer at the moment of
the potential for a negotiated
um solution but of course both sides
will want to be as strong as possible
for that and Putin undoubtedly will want
to take as much ground as he can before
that negotiated so he's got the
strongest hand possible to negotiate any
ceasefire and with this map seeming to
be a bit static for the past few days
what does that tell us about Ukrainian
defense at this point I think they've
been doing a truly outstanding job I
mean they've been overmatched for it by
numbers and in terms of equipment but
it's not just the military the military
and the civilian population have been
doing a truly outstanding job of bravery
and courage of resisting but not only
resisting I think we're seeing the odd
examples of counter-attacks as well uh
happening and although tactically they
may have little in impact on the overall
outcome of the war trust me as an
offense it's very startling if your
enemy now starts to take the initiative
because if you're purely defensive you
leave all the initiative with the
offense if you now start to just catch
him out at the sides he's left second
guessing and reeling and a Ukrainian
doing a really good really good job of
that and to keep them guessing let's
take a look at where there has been some
progress in this one that's in the
southern portion of Ukraine the Russians
have been making some advances we know
that Harrison who has taken a week or so
ago and of course we've seen fighting in
and around maripole that's a airstrike
on that theater just yesterday tell us
about why this part of Ukraine is so
important to the Russian Advance well a
couple of reasons I think really one of
which if you look historically go back
200 years ago Russia owned the whole of
this Coastline and therefore if you are
subscribed to the view that Putin hails
back to the Russian Empire he wants to
take that land again but also from a
more tactical perspective Putin owns the
Crimea down to the South so he also got
mother Rush as the East having a land
bridge that links those 2 for resupply
is really important and of course Mario
poll is is the sort of saw in that whole
strategy and therefore that's undastly
going to be one of his priorities okay
for now thank you very much